all right so to all of you who were a
little sad that I like wrath of the
Titans a little more than I thought I
would because you like seeing me just
really tear into a movie don't fret
don't frown I just saw Mirror Mirror
Mirror Mirror I'm sure there's a on the
wall what's the worst movie of them all
a joke in there somewhere but you know
that's too easy
so mirror mirror is yet another
retelling of the snow-white tale in
which Julia Roberts is the evil witch
queen some really hot chick is Snow
White the wincle vibe from the social
network is the prince and then there are
Seven Dwarves I recognize two of these
guys from other movies and that's it so
just to let you know I won't compare
this movie to Snow White in the Huntsman
for a couple of reasons one I have not
yet seen snow white in the Huntsman and
two I'm pretty sure Mirror Mirror fails
all on its own without being compared to
a movie that's not even out yet it tries
to be this hip edgy and up-to-date
version of Snow White while still taking
place in the you know faraway enchanted
lands of fairies and dwarves and evil
witches but it just comes across as this
grade beast snow-white tail that no one
gave a [ __ ] about when they were making
it like the director of the cell and
immortals was like a yellow straw
bastard like usual ooh this makes Snow
White and make it PG yeah now we have
this when I saw the trailer to Mirror
Mirror I was like that looks like a
movie of the week on the Disney Channel
I'm sure it was meant to be and then
Julia Roberts signed on to be the Evil
Queen they were like oh we can't put her
on network television I'll write
theatrical release I guess I mean look
at the sets - the sets looks so small
when they're in the woods it's supposed
to look like they're in the woods it
looks like a soundstage that's about as
big as my bedroom it's just one of the
many reasons that has that movie of the
week on the Disney Channel vibe then we
have Julia Roberts speaking in the
accent of what I think is the land far
far away she speaks like this enough
salts in the time of time in the Third
Age first of his name then she talks
like Julia Roberts and loses her accent
you know she wants to be a sarcastic and
hip like that what are you Kevin Costner
now you have an accent you don't have an
accent you have it you lose it
make up your mind I'll say this there is
actually a point in the movie where I
was like all right I'm enjoying this and
I even know why no I wasn't put under a
spell or anything although that's
entirely possible
at a point snow white's hanging out with
the dwarves and she's training with him
you know how to be a thief or whatever
and she's trying on new costumes she's
getting hotter
it's a montage scene and I actually kind
of liked I enjoyed the montage scene
probably because no one was talking
really the montage scene
can't really screw them up it's because
nothing takes place in the castle it's
all with Snow White and the dwarves
they're all hanging out and that doesn't
irritate the shada means when you see
anything in the castle anything with
Julia Roberts anything with the Prince
just becomes really cheesy this is scene
in the movie where the prince takes his
love potion he starts acting like a
puppy like eyed puppy dog um and there
was actually a pretty cool scene where
these marionettes are going after the
dwarves and Snow White and it's Julia
Roberts controlling them with strings
but you know they're enormous in real
life that was actually a cool scene now
that it's been ruined for you have no
reason to watch this movie you are
welcome and I know the argument because
I've thought it to myself people will be
like Jeremy this movie's not meant for
you you're not the target audience it's
meant for little kids don't take it so
seriously man I don't take it seriously
but there are a couple things about that
point one I agree it's meant for very
young kids young kids who don't care
what movies are like they'll just like
it because it's a movie and things are
moving on the screen it could be
anything
they don't care when movies are cheesy
they want to see the new Three Stooges
movie in that case though doing a review
about this movie is really pointless
since they're the target audience and
there is no way shape or form they're
gonna read a review or watch one and two
if you're making snow white for little
kids there is already a Snow White for
little kids it's called Snow White in
the Seven Dwarves and if that's made for
little kids and that works for little
kids and this is worse than that then
this movie has no place in the universe
or movies whatsoever which brings up a
point mirror mirror is actually cheesier
and more cartoony than the actual
animation and the actual cartoon you
can't get more ironic than that but it
happens because this movie is clearly
made for little kids who will probably
enjoy it I wanted to give it a great
above dog [ __ ] but I probably would call
it something like it'd be alright if
you're in a coma
in which case let's be honest with
ourselves Mirror Mirror is dog [ __ ] it's
know it was hot Snow White was hot
yeah that's not helping it's a cheesy
corny cartoon version of Snow White
that's made for little kids which is
cheesier and more corny than the actual
cartoon of Snow White that's made for
kids the Cameo of the King broke my
heart though when you see who the king
is man really you're the Lord of
Winterfell buddy you don't need this so
your favorite classic Disney cartoon
this is kind of like Snow White and it
kind of harkens back to that so that's
gonna be my question your favorite
Disney animation what is it comment
below let me know in any case if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]